bonsoir je suis ravi d'être avec vous ce
soir pour envisager les futur désirable
mais avant ça moi aussi je vous propose
un petit jeu on ferme les yeux et on
s'imagine en 2050 et qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait voir
partout
des gens qui mangent des insectes
aïe on peut se dire si tout le monde
mange des insectes c'est ça peut-être
très mal tourner d'ici là on a peut-être
épuisé toutes nos ressources il ya plus
de terre il ya plus d'eau on peut plus
rien cultiver on peut plus rien récolté
est on est on en est réduit à ça
vu comme ça c'est sûr c'est pas super
rassurant ben moi quand je ferme les
yeux et que je vois des gens qui mangent
des insectes
je les imagine plutôt souriant plein de
vitalité avec toutes ces protéines
justement toutes ces vitamines qu'ils
ingèrent et en plus ça me rassure parce
que si en 2050 tout le monde mange des
insectes
c'est peut-être que on aura réussi à les
introduire dans notre alimentation à
partir d'aujourd'hui et si on en mange à
partir d'aujourd'hui c'est autant de gaz
à effet de serre éviter c'est autant de
d'eau et de terres mises de côté autant
de ressources économisées est peut-être
un réchauffement climatique amoindri
on vous dit peut-être j'exagère des six
petites bêtes qui pourrait avoir une
telle puissance c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est l'iphone l'organisation des
nations unies pour l'agriculture et
l'alimentation qui a fait un rapport de
200 pages à une dizaine d'années et qui
dit en substance qu'on est déjà très
nombreux aujourd'hui est que pour nous
nourrir et notamment en protéines
animales on tire énormément sur nos
ressources naturelles et que si on fait
rien à l'horizon en 2050 il se pourrait
bien qu'on soit 9 milliards et que si on
change rien aujourd'hui ça tiendra pas
il faut absolument qu'on trouve des
alternatives et parmi les alternatives
auquel on réfléchit ya justement les
insectes pourquoi les insectes la
première bonne chose la bonne la bonne
raison c'est que c'est bon pour la santé
ils ont un profil nutritionnel tout à
fait équivalent aux meilleures viandes
en termes de protéines vitamines acides
aminés oméga 3 oméga 6 bref c'est pas du
tout un souffle aliments mais ce serait
plutôt un super aliments donc ça c'est
une super raison la deuxième bonne
raison de se mettre à manger des
insectes c'est que c'est bon pour la
planète déjà leur élevage ne génère pas
de gaz à effet de serre c'est la
première chose la deuxième raison c'est
qu'en plus les insectes et des animaux
frugaux ils ont très peu besoin de
ressources pour être élevé si on compare
par exemple la ressource en alimentation
qu'il faut pour faire un kilo de boeuf à
un kilo de vers de farine qui je ne sais
plus si je le dédie son équivalent en
termes de protéines c'est à dire qu'un
kilo de boeuf ou un kilo de vers de
farine dans les deux cas ça fait 200 g
de protéines et bien il faut 15 kg de
céréales juste pour un kilo de boeuf
donc c'est déjà pas mal alors qu'il ne
faut que deux qui ôte son pour faire la
même chose en vers de farine et ce qui
est bien aussi avec le son c'est que
c'est un coproduit un déchet de du blé
donc qui à disposition et qu'on peut
pour lequel on n'a pas besoin de
défricher de nouvelles terres pour faire
leur nourriture
au niveau de l'espace mobiliser pour
faire un kilo de boeuf il nous faut 300
m² ça comprend la terre dans laquelle
sur laquelle les boeufs et les vaches ps
est aussi la terre qui est nécessaire à
l'agriculture pour les nourrir pour
faire du soja il faut pas mal de place
aux 6 10 17 mètres carrés camp pour
faire un kilo de vers de farine faut
même pas 1 mètre carré en plus les
insectes sont élevés dans des
environnements clos on peut très bien
imaginer à l'avenir des élevages dans
des bâtiments réaffecté à ça donc on ne
touche aucune terre et on peut en mettre
vraiment beaucoup parce que c'est élever
les vers de farine sont élevés dans des
caisses de 60 cm sur 40 cm on peut en
tirer un kilo et on les empile donc dans
un petit élevage on peut déjà mettre pas
mal et il ya des énormes élevage qui
sont en train de se développer des
fermes verticales ou on en met des
grandes grandes quantités
dernières ressources qu'on va pouvoir
épargner si on se met à manger des
insectes c'est l'eau parce que les vers
de farine par exemple comme pas mal
d'autres insectes ne boivent pas
beaucoup d'eau les vers de farine pas du
tout il absorbe l'humidité ambiante ils
peuvent aussi récupérer un peu
d'humidité avec les fruits et légumes
avec lesquels au complément de leur
alimentation tandis que le boeuf demande
énormément d'eau le soja aussi
cerise sur le gâteau les déjections des
vers de farine contrairement aux
déjections de d'autres animaux d'élevage
c'est un fertilisant naturel acquis et
c'est rare et enrichir les sols en
l'état quand on rentre dans un élevage
un kilo de son blé on en sort 400 g de
verre à peu près et 600 g de déjections
prête à l'emploi pourraient enrichir les
sols dans la crypte dans l'agriculture
biologique mais également pour faire
pour les plantes d'ornement là ici sur
la photo que vous voyons on a fait des
petits tests avec des fleurs plantes et
sans guano le client du des déjections
et avec guano à droite on voit que le
guano profite énormément à la plante
donc ben mathieu mon mari et moi quand
on a découvert ce rapport de la fao on
s'est dit qu'on n'allait pas attendre
2050 et qui soit presque trop tard pour
nous mettre à manger des insectes et on
a dégagé 5 copains 10 mètres carrés
pardon au rez-de-chaussée notre maison
en plein centre-ville à marcq en baroeul
pour y mettre des vers de farine des
grillons et des criques et on est
complètement autodidacte au niveau de
l'élevage c'est pas du tout notre
formation donc on a cherché sur internet
il ya plein de tutos de petits jeunes
qui qui élèvent des insectes est qui et
qui nous ont donné les tuyaux on est
allé faire une petite formation aussi
dans le sud chez une amie on est revenu
avec des insectes qu'on a élevé et très
vite on s'est retrouvé avec des kilos
d'insectes à manger au niveau de la
façon de les cuisiner on n'y connaissait
rien donc on a improvisé
et on a découvert que c'était bon tout
naturellement revenu à la poêle avec un
petit peu de sel c'est bon donc je
propose à une ou deux personnes
volontaires dans la salle pour venir
goûter un verre
ou abba venait
cela il ya un petit peu des pistes mais
il n'y a pas du tout de matière grasse 1
c'est juste cuisiner et
ah
ça vous plaît
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
là il ya un petit peu de dépit
il y en aura aussi à la pause ainsi
vous pourriez venir ici
ça fait plus que ce que je pensais
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est vrai
bon après je vais poursuivre parce que
s'il vous plaît
ça me fait plaisir
et bien dans ma famille on s'est dit la
même chose quand on s'est mis à les
déguster que c'était très très bon donc
on en a mangé déshydraté et de cette
façon là puis très vite apprend les a
réduits en poudre pour les intégrer dans
toutes sortes de préparations comme des
pancakes j'en ai encore fait ce matin
mes enfants tout comme ça ça apporte la
protéine dès le petit déjeuner on peut
le mettre dans le pain dans le crumble
[Musique]
ensuite on a
avec les vers de farine toujours où on a
élaboré une farce d'insectes de vers de
farine puis mais non déshydraté pour
mélanger des céréales pour en façonner
des galettes qu'on met dans nos burgers
ou dans la version asiatique qui est le
bad moon dans les kebabs les tacos enfin
bref la farce elle nous permet de faire
toutes sortes de préparations
trop tard il y avait aussi les merguez
et les boulettes de notre couscous ou la
force qu'on met dans nos ravioles ça
c'était pour les vers de farine pour les
criques et les grillons s'amuser ou
aussi à remplacer à revisiter certaines
cuisines recettes de cuisine française
en remplaçant bas le homard et les
crevettes dans la bisque de cliquer et
les croquettes de grillons
pourquoi on a fait ça parce que ben les
homards et les crevettes seller cousin
de la mère des criques et des grillons
qui sont des fruits de terre ils sont de
la même famille génétique et leur
exosquelette leur donne exactement le
même vous donc c'est difficile à croire
peut-être mais quand on mange une bisque
de criques et on voit à peine la
différence avec une bisque de homard
pareil pour les croquettes devrions donc
c'est un très bon plein un très bon
point pour eux et on s'est rendu compte
en fait au fur et à mesure qu'on peut
vraiment manger les insectes plein plein
de façons entiers naturels en poudre de
façon plus gastronomique
d'ailleurs à ce propos on allait il ya
quinze jours il ya deux mois par don
fait une collaboration avec un
restaurant étoilé du vieux-lille le
stories y en ville qui nous a fait une
chez gastronomique composé d'un sablé
parmesan et vers de farine avec 50% de
vers de farine surmonté d'un velouté
d'une émulsion pardon carottes et
criques et et il habite deux petits
insectes sur le top pour le fun mais
l'idée c'est vraiment de mettre un
maximum d'insectes pour que ce soit
nutri enfin nutritifs un
haut niveau de l'élevage les 10 mètres
carrés de notre rez-de-chaussée n'ont
pas suffi on s'est vite senti à l'étroit
donc on a développé un partenariat avec
ea pf france handicap sur leur esat des
terres d'opale à calais on élève
maintenant des vers de farine toujours
et on en récolte une centaine de kilos
par mois on récolte et qu'on transforme
sur place et pour lesquelles on fait la
promotion de lento mot culture et de
lento food auprès de différents publics
des entreprises des institutions et on
présente tous les produits qu'on propose
d'ailleurs on n'est pas les seuls à le
faire heureusement il ya plein d'autres
initiatives dans ce sens on en voit de
plus en plus
les on n'en voit pas encore tellement
dans les magasins parce que il ya de ça
quelques années les autorités sanitaires
nous ont imposé une demande de mise sur
le marché cette demande c'est un dossier
qui coûte 20 qui prend beaucoup de temps
et qui coûte beaucoup d'argent en
analyse pour montrer pour prouver que le
produit est sûre et simple pour la santé
les dossiers la plupart ont été déposés
il ya trois quatre ans maintenant on
commence à voir les premiers retours il
ya encore une vingtaine de dossiers dont
on doit avoir les retours l'année
prochaine et on espère qu'à partir de là
ça va ouvrir la voie à tous ceux qui ont
envie de cuisiner proposé chez eux ou
dans les restaurants des insectes pour
un futur désirable je vous remercie je
vous souhaite un bon appétit